warning this episode of film theory is
not safe for work oh hey you thought I
met it was full of naked people or
violence or heavy swearing right it's no
no no I mean today we're talking about
Willy Wonka and his Chocolate Factory
and no when I say Chocolate Factory
that's not meant to be some kind of
weird and you window get your minds out
of the gutter people
hello Internet welcome to film theory
your golden ticket to a ruined childhood
today's video it's really close to home
for me because we're talking about one
of my all-time favorite childhood films
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
sure as a kid I thought Wonka's factory
was the most fanciful fantastic place to
visit ever I mean there are mushrooms
where you can scoop out with cream and
eat it in the main building knock down
some of the candies from that tree no
not now but now that I'm an adult and
have people who work for me I see it as
the horrendously unsafe sweatshop that
it is so unsafe in fact that it would be
literally illegal to produce a single
bar of chocolate on there so get ready
to melt down those childhood dreams and
send them down the chocolaty river of
disappointment because not only does mr.
William Wonka have one of the most
illegal factories on the entire planet
but what's worse I can prove to you that
he actually knows it
yes there is Wonka you've been pulling
the wool over our eyes for far too long
my friend and today I'm exposing the
grand conspiracy of your golden ticket
giveaway like the nougaty inside of a
scrumdiddlyumptious far so loyal
theorists get ready to come with me and
you'll be in case you're not up to speed
with a super saccharine sweatshop that
is Wonka's chocolate factory here's the
quick rundown eccentric candy maker
genius Willy Wonka runs a Chocolate
Factory with SpaceX levels of security
nobody that comes out to protect his
candy making secrets from his
sticky-fingered competitors who for some
reason can't seem to figure out that all
you need to do is mix cocoa powder
together with butter sugar and vanilla
I mean seriously slugworth there just
aren't that many ingredients in
chocolate maybe sprinkle in some nuts or
toffee if you're feeling dangerous in
both versions of the movie the modern
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory as
well as the vastly superior original
version Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory which is the one I'm gonna be
focused on for this theory Wonka opens
his doors up to five lucky kids who
begged borrowed and stolen to get their
hands on one of his five golden tickets
as they tour the factory we as the
movie-going audience get a first-hand
look at the unbelievable wonders and
hazards that Wonka has littered
everywhere
these are just some little issues that
make life around the factory
inconvenient these are occupational
safety and health administration
violations or OSHA violations
they're illegal they're life-threatening
and they are everywhere and here's the
interesting thing about OSHA violations
they don't just come with a little
finger wag and a couple of demerits on
your business owner report card they
come with fines huge fines and enough of
them will totally be able to shut down
your business for good so let's figure
out how big of a legal tab that willy
wonka's racked up for himself
the suspense is terrible the first
violation seemed pretty small but it'll
give you a sense of what real-world
business owners face when they're trying
to create a safe work environment for
their employees see if you can spot it
in this clip
hey the room is getting smaller no it's
not he's getting bigger did you catch
that one inside of this room all of my
dreams become realities you know what
else is gonna become a reality for you a
big whopping fine Code of regulations
twenty nine part 1910 subpart e point
thirty-seven eye OSHA says that all
ceilings must be seven foot six inches
or higher this is specifically for fire
safety in the event that the exit needs
to be used as an emergency exit but just
think this is where we are starting if
Wonka is getting a fine for the height
of a measly hallway then you know that
old Willy is in for a long night
or a long episode of film theory next
the chocolate room the centerpiece of my
childhood dreams and my current dreams
and the horrific nightmares of an OSHA
agent in this scene you'll see that
Veruca Salt cuts herself on a rock in
the room well it turns out that that was
real blood and that the actress who
played her Julie dawn Cole still has a
scar from that injury on set which she
got from one of the jagged rocks that
were used as props in the set a
workplace injury in the movies as well
as a workplace injury in the factory
that's fine number two there are a few
other pedantic things in here to find
including the stairs that one belugas
walked down those are under the 22 inch
minimum width required by building codes
and they don't have a vertical banister
so that's fines number three and four
okay I hear you a little cut a little
banister a little hallway come on that
sort of stuff could be fixed in a day so
who cares
well first off who should care is the
business owner because all those things
may be little to you if they result in
big fines thousands of dollars for small
infractions like that and we're only
just beginning let's get to the big ones
like the chocolate River first you have
food running through an open-air Factory
that is a huge strike there the workers
around it also aren't wearing any
protective or sterile clothing and
literally anyone who touches the
chocolate contaminates the entire supply
as Augustus so kindly demonstrates for
us
contaminating the entire River Wonka
says as he doesn't shut his Factory down
to clean out the sweaty child floating
in the chocolate so here we have no
guardrails no protective clothing
working with contaminated food and
failing to clean up those contaminations
all of these are OSHA violations for
basic safety with the contamination
issue getting some nice extra scrutiny
from the Food Drug Administration and as
a fun fact if Augustus is germ-ridden
body did in fact make someone sick from
a chocolate bar on the other end Wonka
would be responsible for fines of around
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
at the time of the movie release or
about 1.5 million dollars in today's
terms per person made sick since we have
no way of knowing the fallout from
Augustus is chocolate dip we can't
really count these but they would
literally be enough to put the factory
out of business if they happen to ship
those contaminated chocolate bars out
that being said we're still not done
with the violations that we can count in
this room which include the fact that
once someone actually falls into the
chocolate River they get suctioned up
into a huge unfiltered pipe she's had it
now the suctions gutter leading to them
possibly drowning and suffocating and if
you survive all of that there's still a
good chance that you get boiled alive
look sharp or her little boys are able
to get poured into the boiler so strike
for the unfiltered pipe an additional
strike for no safety protocol moving
further into the movie we survive a
traumatizing boat ride which is
shockingly one of the safest things in
this entire movie this is somehow
actually okay don't worry we're about to
hit Wonka's secret inventing room the
place where candy and lawsuits get made
first of all all those steaming vats are
violations of OSHA's rules around hot
plates in the workplace reference number
nineteen ten point two six one sub point
k eleven quote all exposed steam and hot
water pipes within seven feet of the
floor shall be covered with an
insulating material or guarded and you
guessed it each VAT or pipe counts as a
separate violation so uh let's see here
we have eight of those oh and no
guardrails again you think you're slick
Willie this is just laziness oh and
there are live bees in this room so yeah
that counts too and last up there also
seems to be a complete lack of safety
equipment anywhere unless of course you
count the oompa-loompa fabric Mickey
Mouse style gloves
you may wearing rubber gloves you love
the Elton's makes it up here you know
that oh yeah right you are mr. salt it
would have made a good film theorists
osha code 19 ten point one three to a
requires that quote protective equipment
including personal protective equipment
for eyes face head and extremities is
provided used and maintained in any
situation involving food or chemicals
and we know plenty of chemicals being
used in this room are well to put it
lightly hazardous you're turning violet
violet the next workplace hazard is in
the fizzy lifting drink room where
Charlie and Grandpa Joe float away and
almost get themselves chopped to bits by
the fan blades at the top of the room
like he just said now here's the thing a
fan at the top of a room this tall isn't
a violation but OSHA would still be able
to book Wonka for negligence in making
the room with the deadly ceiling the
same room with the soda that makes you
float if you read the book the movies
based on Wonka even mentions that a few
Oompa Loompas that they didn't tie down
float it off into the blue but we're
just gonna let those slide because we're
focused on the on-screen versions but
still you're an awful person Willy Wonka
moving right along we get to see Veruca
shining moment with the golden geese
where she wrecks up a jackpot of fines
you see all those boxes crashing down on
the uber lupus so that's right OSHA has
regulations against stacking boxes too
high in fact anything stacked over five
feet has to be secured so it doesn't
fall over like you see right here in the
scene so we get ourselves a strike for
every single tall stack that you see in
the room conservatively I'm gonna say
that's about thirteen then of course we
have the famous moment where Veruca
stands on the eggdicator and falls down
the garbage chute into the furnace
[Music]
yep that's another handful of safety
violations no guardrails and open chute
down into the furnace and again a
violation for each eggdicator so that's
at least four separate strikes right
there but hey now we're down to just two
kids so how many violations could be
left in this movie right
oh so many let's start with what happens
when you cover people in soap and send
them through a car wash exposing people
to chemicals including most soaps like
dishwashing detergent is an OSHA
violation in the highest amounts and
they're also on a moving vehicle with no
seat belts so that's a strike for
everyone also as a pun side note these
violations actually also happened in
real life during the shooting of this
very scene where they covered everyone
and so the entire cast puffed up from
all that detergent irritation it took
days of medical treatment for the caster
returned to normal and returned to set
so yeah there are actually reasons for
all these stupid rules being in place go
figure
last up on our tour we start mixing food
violations with electricity what could
possibly go wrong there well even though
they do have safety equipment and no
exposure to chemicals unfortunately
Wonka still getting himself an
infraction for violating the
occupational exposure to hazardous
chemicals in laboratory standard
reference 29 CFR nineteen ten point one
four five zero which specifically covers
labs where this sort of research and
development takes place allowing a small
boy to be able to operate a massive ray
gun with no safety protocol in place
that's a strike and seriously walk up
guard rails guardrails are gonna go a
long way here so are we done with this
death trap yet almost even though our
tour of the factory ends we get one more
bonus strike thrown in for good measure
with our visit to the great glass
elevator which has nothing to stop it
from crashing straight through the glass
roof of the factory so let's just slap
on an extra violation or three for
everyone in that elevator and with that
our grand total comes to sixty OSHA
violations and that's just what you can
see in the movie sixty is very
conservative now like I said at the
beginning of this episode Wonka better
be selling the heck out of those
chocolate bars because every one of
those violations comes with a fine but
now of course we come to the real
question how much are those fines gonna
cost well according to OSHA quote any
employer who willfully were repeatedly
violates the requirements of this Act
may be assessed a civil penalty of not
more than seventy thousand dollars for
each violation but not less than $5,000
for each willful violation end quote but
it's important to mention that these are
the guidelines from 1971 when the
original Wonka movie came out and was
sad in today's numbers that's about
$31,000 two four hundred and thirty six
thousand dollars per individual
violation at lowest Wonka is looking at
a one point eight six million dollar
price tag and at highest he's shelling
out a whopping twenty six point 1
million in today's dollars again just
from the 6000 C violations that we see
in the like six seven eight rooms that
he tours us through now obviously a
range of 5,000 to seventy thousand
dollars is huge what determines which
end of the spectrum you fall on is your
past history and whether it seems like
you as a business owner just made a
mistake or whether you really don't care
about the safety of your workplace so
would you have pity on Willy Wonka the
short answer is definitely not they
factor in things like the seriousness of
the violation which in our case includes
violations like child-sized pipes to a
boiler room in the furnace as well as
exposing children and workers to
chemicals that turn them into
blueberries also a small business is
likely to get off the hook much easier
than a multinational chocolate mega
factory so Wonka has no case to plead
here because he ships to literally every
continent we see it in the golden ticket
coverage and when it comes to showing a
good faith effort to keep things safe
well let's just say that Wonka has a bad
track record there too he's not even
good at pretending stop don't come back
Helen please learn in conclusion mr.
Wonka we film theorists OSHA
investigators find you guilty on every
counts and let's face it probably dozens
more that we don't see in your 90-minute
movie if you sir are looking squarely in
the eye of that twenty six point 1
million dollar fine or 4.2 million
dollars in 1971 terms and if you all
watching at home right now think that's
bad I'm
not even done you see the thing about
safety inspectors is that they don't
just show up once find you and then
leave when you get fined you're also
given an order to fix whatever issues
the inspector discovered when the
inspector returns if they find that you
still haven't fixed the problems then
you get fined again this is called the
failure to abate and that results in its
own fine you pay the same fines again
for every single day that your factory
wasn't in compliance
so 4.2 million inflation-adjusted
dollars isn't just a one-time fee it's
how much mr. Wonka would be paying per
day for as long as all those issues go
unfixed that's 182 million
inflation-adjusted dollars per week and
9.5 billion dollars for a year of
non-compliance for comparison Hershey's
current revenues are about 7.4 to 1
billion dollars per year which would put
Willy Wonka's factory in complete
bankruptcy in a matter of months but and
here's the biggest butt of them all my
friends this is no surprise - Willy
Wonka no in fact he knows about all
these violations better than anyone
you see the Occupational Safety and
Health Act the legislation that created
OSHA in the first place was passed in
1970 it took effect in 1971 the exact
same year that Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory is set in the year
that had hit theaters with the
establishment of OSHA laws in 1970 Willy
Wonka realized pretty fast that his
factory wasn't long for this world given
the way he runs it and how dangerous it
is to everyone inside
so Wonka's decision to open his factory
to five lucky children a decision that
seems to come out of nowhere in the
movie his show isn't actually motivated
by a desire to do good or even passes
love of chocolate and candy making
secrets unlike a legacy no it's to
offload this dumpster fire of a business
onto one poor vulnerable unsuspecting
child before Wonka himself is hit with
all these fines
Charlie who comes out of destitution and
thinks he's hit the lottery with his
golden ticket believes he's inheriting
Wonka's fortune but the truth is that
he's actually inheriting Willy Wonka's
massive legal trouble and billions of
dollars of debt he's not the most pure
of heart or the nicest or whatever he's
just the biggest chump and the child in
the most desperate situation that Wonka
can prey on to escape OSHA and a
lifetime of corporate debt but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and I
know that it's a little disappointing
that all our candy-coated dreams have
been destroyed by this episode but if
you're looking for a much sweeter deal
than just five golden tickets well then
check out our partner for today's
episode Dollar Shave Club yes I already
use the razors you've heard me talk
about him and you already know that
those things are great but those are
gonna keep your body from stinking up
the great glass elevator or they're not
gonna get your mouth clean after even
one too many scrumdiddlyumptious bars
and that's why Dollar Shave Club is no
longer just the shave club they've
expanded to everything from toothpaste
to hairstyling products so you know that
you're gonna be looking and feeling your
best whether you're being blown up like
a blueberry or sucked away to a boiler
room they should rebrand themselves as
the dollar look good feel good Club
anyway just imagine if these children
had used one of their great products if
Augustus had just used that smooth as
silk shaving butter then shoo
he's not getting stuck in that pipe he's
shooting through that thing like a
rocket buttery smooth like a baby's
bottom and tell you what verrucas gonna
have herself a mess down below after her
brush with a boiler room of death well
she can take care of that mess in one
wipe with a Dollar Shave Club one white
charlie but white and here's the best
part you don't need to be a spoiled rich
kid to afford it so don't be a Veruca
join the club for only five dollars at
dollarshaveclub.com slash film theory fi
lm th EO ry or you know just save
yourself the trouble and click the link
on the top line of the description new
members are getting their first month of
the daily essential starter kit for only
$5 so you can try out a lot of the new
products that I just mentioned see how
cool they are and decide which ones are
the ones that you want to keep showing
up conveniently
at your door every month if only
everything in life for that sweet
remember that's dollarshaveclub.com /
film theory click the link below and
you've got yourself a golden ticket to
personal hygiene click it now